The first thing I already explained to
you that about the shift in our emphasis
from here on in
and I suppose in some ways where we're
switching from the part of the purse,
of course it has to do with
transformation into the part of the
course that has to do with stability,
at least relative stability.
Now the idea behind the work that we're
going to talk about now is that
personality has stable and identifiable
features across time and I suppose it's
traits that you're referring to when you
say to yourself or to someone else,
I know that person
and when you say that you know that
person,
it seems to me that you're presuming
that there's something stable and
identifiable about them that you can
track over time.
You might consider that who they are
and so trait theory
is the study
of who people are.
Now,
if there's 17,000 trait descriptors in
the English language,
that suggests in some way that there are
17,000 ways that people can vary or be
the same.
No vary from each other and be the same
across time.
But 17,000 seems like not an
unmanageable number and it's possible
that
a very large number of those words are
variance there,
synonyms in some sense,
and trait theory in some ways is an
attempt to find
the clumps of synonymous words that are
encapsulated within language that apply
to people.
The basic hypothesis is something like
this
because tracking the behavior of other
people is extremely important to us and
because we want to communicate about
that tracking and because we're studying
each other all the time,
there's at least a reasonable
probability that the fundamental
dimensions of personality are going to
be encapsulated within the language and
what that means in some senses that you
may be able to use the language as a
tool if you use the appropriate
statistical techniques in order to
extract out the fundamental dimensions
of personality.
And so you could say those are the
basic.
Imagine there's five or six canonical
words or 10 canonical words within that
collection of 17,000 and then all the
others are slight variance of the more
mixtures of them more or something like
that.
So perhaps there's a simple structure
underneath the apparent complexity.
The first people who tried this,
as I said,
we're all part allport and Odbert,
but they really didn't have the
statistical techniques that were
necessary to do a particularly good job.
So,
uh,
all port Nordberg tried to reduce their
18,000 treat terms to 4,500 descriptors
of what they figured we're stable
traits.
And then cattle came along in 1942
restricted those two,
171 by judgment.
And then further to 16 by factor
analysis.
These are cattell 16 traits.
The first three were the most important.
You could be reserved versus outgoing,
less or more intelligent,
emotional versus stable,
humble versus assertive,
sober versus happy,
go lucky.
Expedient versus conscientious,
shy versus fincher,
some tough tender minded,
trusting,
suspicious,
practical,
imaginative,
forthright,
shrewd,
placid,
apprehensive,
conservative or experimental,
group oriented yourself,
sufficient casual versus controlled and
relaxed versus tense.
And cattell 16 personality theory
dominated the field for,
for quite a long time,
really,
until the early 19 sixties.
Um,
now we'll go back,
tell you a little bit about how these
things are measured.
Here's some,
here's some definitions of what a trait
might be.
This is the theoretical theories or
theoretical propositions.
The trade has more than a normal
existence.
What does that mean?
Well,
it refers to something that's outside
its linguistic marker,
so hypothetically there's something
about a trait that that makes it real.
That might be physiological or
biological or at least behavioral that
that that can be examined.
The outside mirror subjective analysis,
although that's often proved more
difficult than people originally
expected traits are more generalized in
particular habits.
Oh God only knows how many habits people
have.
You know,
when you kind of maybe you run into the
same problem with habits as you do with
with 17,000 words.
There's so many of them that you know
you can drown in the description and
again,
you have to look for something that's
more fundamental.
They're dynamic and determined behavior,
so there's something about a trait that
in some sense acts as a causal agent,
traits me be identified empirically.
We covered that.
Traits are relatively independent of
other traits.
They're not synonymous with moral or
social judgements and acts and even
habits that are inconsistent with a
trait or not proof of the nonexistence
of that trait.
And then the more complex one trades me
either be viewed video graphically in
light of the personality that contains
them or nomothetically on the basis of
their distribution in the population
measurement techniques.
So imagine that you collect your list of
adjectives and then
you transform them into a very simple
questionnaire.
And so the questionnaire would look like
a list of adjectives down the lefthand
side.
And then on the righthand side there'd
be maybe a scale that's yes or no or
maybe a scale from one to seven.
And so if the descriptor was
intelligent,
you could ask the person apply that
descriptor to yourself on a scale from
one to seven.
Or You could ask the person to rate
someone else and describe that person as
intelligent on a scale of one to seven.
And then you can have,
let's say a large group of adjectives
like that.
Three hundred or so.
And then you can have a large number of
people assess themselves with all those
adjectives and you can apply statistical
techniques that then allow you to
determine how the data is pattern.
So for example,
if two of the 400 words,
we're intelligent and smart,
and you might find that within the
entire population of raiders,
if they are rating themselves,
if they rated themselves as high on
intelligence,
they're also going to rate themselves as
high on smart and maybe high on quick
and maybe high on insightful.
And then you may also find,
for example,
that if they rated themselves as nice,
highly,
they might also rate themselves as kind,
highly or empathic highly.
And so by analyzing the groups of words
that clumped together in the same
direction across many,
many people,
you can start to in and you can do this
statistically,
you can start to infer what the
fundamental dimensions of variation are.
Now it's taken a long time for people to
get the fundamental dimensions of
variation right?
And part of the problem is,
well,
how do you reduce the pool of adjectives
to begin with to something that's
because you're not going to have,
you know,
a thousand people rate themselves on 17
adjectives,
that's just not going to go very well,
so you have to reduce that in some way
that's not exactly biased and then you
have to get enough people to fill it out
so that your sample is going to be
reliable across time.
And then you have to have statistical
techniques that are powerful enough to
handle those operations.
And that already didn't come together
until probably the early 19,
60,
something like that.
When,
when when cartels 16 factors were
finally reduced to something
approximating five.
Now I'm going to tell you a little bit
how you would go about making a
questionnaire because that's part of
what you need to know in order to do
experimental psychology,
especially social and personality
psychology.
And so we'll step into method a little
bit before we returned to the,
to the trait theories.
So if you want it to measure something,
let's see someone think of a potential
personality trait.
Don't,
don't use the standard big five how.
Give me a word that you might use to
describe someone
fun.
Okay,
good.
So now,
now we have to figure out.
So now we've got a problem and the
problem is,
well,
you can use fun as a marker in a
linguistic exchange.
Joe is a fun person to hang around with
and then
part of the meaning that you attribute
to fund is a consequence of the words
that you surrounded with and then of
course the context in which you uttered
the sentence and your determination of
whether or not the person you're talking
to knows who joe is and and so you're
always providing the person that you're
communicating with.
When you use a word like fun with a
bunch of information that sort of
surrounds the word so that they can
infer what you meet,
but if you're going to
use that word and infer that it actually
ref refers to something that's objective
outside language,
then you have to go about it in a
different way.
And so the first thing you try to do is
to figure out,
okay,
what do you mean by fun?
Exactly.
So let's have some characteristics of a
person who's fun.
What do they like?
We can't use big five descriptors.
That's,
that's okay.
But that's,
that's right,
by the way.
But
I want to stay away from that just just
for
funny.
Okay.
So a funny,
a fun person is funny and so a funny
person is someone who makes you laugh,
I presume.
And who's witty?
And so you could start generating
associated words.
Okay.
What else makes a person fun?
They're interesting.
Okay.
So they're funny and they're
interesting.
What else?
Friendly.
Okay.
Enthusiastic,
talkative,
lighthearted,
lighthearted.
Alright,
you guys are really getting into this
now.
Okay.
So you're starting to surround the word
with a cloud of additional words that
you believe in.
Some,
in some ways have some important
similarity with that underlying work.
Right?
They seem to belong in the same
category.
Okay.
What are some words that,
that indicate that someone's not fun.
Okay.
So they're boring,
miserable,
miserable.
What's the difference between boring and
miserable?
That's a good one.
Yeah.
Misery can be interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
So are other differences between boring
and miserable?
That's probably an open answer by the
way.
Just just so you know,
any other differences?
Come on.
You guys know the difference between
boring and miserable for God's sake.
Yeah.
Boring.
Okay.
So boring sounds like it's more neutral
in some sense.
Miserable.
Was that,
is that a positive thing or negative
thing?
Negative.
Okay.
So,
and what sort of emotions might it be
associated with depression?
Sadness,
depression.
What else?
Anxiety.
Hate,
hate.
Fear.
Cynicism.
Okay.
So
now we've got the fun person sort of
identified with regards to a positive
pole at a negative pole.
Right?
Alright.
So
you can conduct a brief statistical
investigation to determine whether or
not your characterization of fun had any
utility was,
was,
was valid in some sense and reliable and
valid.
So the first thing we might do is write
down all those words on a,
on a little questionnaire.
So we probably generated about 20 of
them,
me and then we might ask everyone to
rate themselves according to that
questionnaire.
And then we,
we might submit the
data set to factor analysis,
which is a complicated form of
correlation analysis,
and then we could find out what words
clump together.
Now what we would find if we analyzed
all the words that you guys generated is
that we'd have one little clump that was
associated with interesting and we'd
have another clump that was associated
with negative emotion and we'd have
another clump that was associated with
positive emotion.
And so you guys actually define fun as a
three dimensional construct from given
what we know about personality,
because we know that there's a positive
emotion dimension at a negative emotion
dimension.
And then another dimension that's
associated with creativity and so from,
for at least in so far as you all
characterized it,
fund is not a unidimensional word.
It,
it crosses a variety of different
domains now.
So if you're,
if you're trying to get at how to
measure fun,
the first thing you have to do is define
it.
And that's what we're trying to do.
When we were collecting up all these
words.
I'll show you how cattle in 1965
characterized conscientiousness.
So he says,
well,
this thing exists,
and in its existence it manifests these
characteristics.
Conscientious is conscientiousness is
that disposition,
governing,
persevering,
unselfish behavior,
and impelling the individual to duty as
conceived by his or her culture.
A conscientious person is honest,
knows what is right and generally does
it even if no one is watching him or her
does not tell lies or attempt to deceive
others,
respects other's property and
unconscientious person is somewhat
unscrupulous,
not too careful about standards of right
and wrong,
were personal desires are concerned,
tells lies and is given a little
receipts and does not respect others'
property.
So you can imagine how you could
transform that definition into a
questionnaire.
You could use the adjectives that are in
it and just have people rate themselves
by the adjectives.
Or you could use little phrase phrases
like,
do you respect others?
Property one to seven,
I'm,
do you have a strong sense of the
difference between right and wrong?
If you know what's right,
do you generally do it?
Are you a persistent person?
Are you unselfish?
So you can extract out individual items
from your sort of global definition of
what constitutes the hypothetical trait
and there's some of the examples.
You usually keep emotions under control.
Are you a person who is scrupulously
correct and manners and social
obligations and likes others to be the
same?
Are you cautious and considerate so that
you do not hurt people's feelings by
unconsidered conversational remarks?
I liked the adjective approach in some
ways because you might notice that the
last question there plumps a number of
descriptors together and it isn't
absolutely certain that all those
descriptors belong in the same question.
And so I would say this is was
constructed quite a long time ago and I
would say if you're going to construct
questions you should try to answer,
you try to ask as close to one thing as
possible because otherwise the question
gets confusing.
So I would say the,
you know,
the second question also has the same
problem.
All right?
So if you're going to make your
questionnaire and let's say you're,
you're trying to figure out how fun
someone is
and simultaneously figure out whether or
not investigating fund is actually a
reasonable thing to do.
We'd like,
is it,
is it a scientifically valid category?
Then you might want to generate whole
bunch of items and also put some in
there that don't obviously measure fun.
So let's have some descriptors that
don't seem to fall on the fun non-funded
dimension.
What's outside of that?
Okay.
Which one?
I would say.
Okay.
And defined.
STOIC.
Careful with your words not having an
excess of emotional.
Okay.
So.
So you think you could you think you can
be fun to not have an excess of
emotional response and I'm not trying to
put you on the spot,
I'm just,
I'm just wondering if that's what you're
claiming
because just because you're a situation.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what,
what other,
what other descriptors?
Look,
I mean fun can't mean everything,
right?
Because if it means and everything,
then it's not a useful word because the
word has to be some things and not other
things.
That's
convergent.
Divergent validity in a sense.
A word can't mean everything.
It has to be something specific.
So what does,
what's outside of the fund?
Non funded me.
Yeah.
So you can be fun and stupid fact,
fact that might even be easier.
Alright.
So intelligence might be outside of
that.
What else might be.
And you could be envious and fund still
seems least probable.
How about me?
Can you be mean and fun?
Yeah.
So that's kind of interesting.
So,
so
okay.
Okay.
So now we're starting to get the idea
that fun circumscribes one dimension,
but there are other potential dimensions
variation outside of that that might be
interesting to look at.
And so we've sort of thought about,
we thought sort of thought about.
I mean,
you know,
we thought about intelligent.
What else did we come up with?
What else is sort of outside of the fun
realm?
Patient.
Okay.
So you can be impatient fund or patient
fun.
Alright.
Seems reasonable.
Fashionable.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is that,
do you think that's a person who said
that you think that's a personality
trait?
I think it means that you pay
it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so you,
you definitely do think it's a
personality characteristic and that
that's fine.
It could well be,
you know,
um,
is there a difference between a
personality characteristic and an
emotion
you think?
Do you think emotion is inside
personality?
So it's nested inside it.
The personality is the larger category
of emotion is the smaller category.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a funny thing because there's lots
of,
there's lots of a priority suppositions
in psychology that you have to watch out
for.
And one of them is that just because
there's different words for different
things,
that doesn't mean those different things
really exists separately as separate
things do in scientific terminology.
So for example,
the relationship between personality
traits and emotions and values is
relatively unclear whether those things
belong in the same or different
categories is by no means clear and
people will claim that they do.
But um,
the overlap is substantial,
so.
Okay.
Yes.
We also usually think of emotions as
being more like we're all,
we all experienced sadness itself
doesn't mean that that's a fundamental
trait of our personality,
like we're all able to experience it
usually defined who we are unless we're
right and so and so.
Okay.
And so that's part of the definition of
a trait as something that's enduring
rather than transient.
Okay.
So you could say that's actually a
hypothesis.
Your hypothesis is that what we refer to
as emotions are brief flare ups of some
of the phenomena that we would consider
traits if,
if they were enduring.
Yeah.
And that's,
I mean that's a reasonable hypothesis.
Although if you,
if you describe a person as sad,
do you think you're describing their
personality or their emotion?
It could be either.
I would normally think,
yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well it's a tricky.
It's tricky business.
Okay.
So the reason I had you generate all
these additional words just because you
need to find out that your category fun
has a bunch of things that it doesn't
cover as well as a bunch of things that
it does.
And so we've hypothesized a number of
things that might constitute additional
domains of variation,
and so you might want to throw those
into your questionnaire too.
Okay.
Now
he might say,
well,
what are you going to do with your
scale?
So
you now you have a scale and you can
give it to people and you can tell the
difference between the fund people in
the not fun people.
And so what might be some practical
purposes towards which you could put
that knowledge.
You don't have to be too serious about
it.
I mean,
what are you going to.
You could invite all the non-funded
people to a party that would seem rather
counterproductive.
You're your hypothesis would be that
maybe you'd have two parties,
we'd have a party with all the fun
people and you'd have another party with
all non fund people and then you could
get the attendees to rate how fun the
party was.
And then that would help you determine
whether or not your measurement of fund
was actually practically useful for
something that's called criterion
related validity,
by the way.
So and criterion related validity.
If a scale possesses criteria and
related to the liquidity,
you can identify something that might
predict that doesn't like completely
obviously associated with the initial
measure,
although you know,
fun and fun and a party probably are.
So that's a bad example,
but you can use it to predict something
that might be a value.
So I can give you an example of that is
that conscientiousness for which is a
trade from his is frequently used to
evaluate how good an employee might be
if you hired them or even how good a
student might be because
conscientiousness turns out to be a
pretty good predictor of academic
achievement.
Okay?
So if you're going to make us,
if you want to make a questionnaire and
some of you will do this when you do
your honors thesis or if you're involved
in research at all and people tend to
think about developing a questionnaire
or something that's relatively
straightforward.
Um,
it's not.
You need to figure out what it is that
you're after.
You know,
what's your central construct of
interest.
And then you have to figure out,
well how do I generate a very large
number of items that hypothetically
measures this or it's reversed or it's
opposite,
it doesn't really matter.
And then a bunch of items that don't
measure it because again,
you have to show that it's good for
something and not good for everything.
So and then you have to demonstrate
statistically that your,
your concept is coherent and then you
have to show that you can use it to
predict something and it gets worse than
that actually.
Then you have to show that it predicts
something better than some other thing
that someone already invented.
So you know,
if,
if you came up with a fun scale,
it's probably primarily extroversion
that has,
as you mentioned,
that a scale like that would measure,
although it'd be a little complicated
because generally fun people also have
less negative emotion.
So what you'd end up with,
as we mentioned before,
that your fund scale would be a mangling
up of a couple of different categories.
And so it probably ended up not being a
very good questionnaire at all.
So it's a tricky thing to make a
questionnaire,
it takes an awful lot of work and you,
you,
you can't start with the assumption that
just because you've been able to think
up a concept that it actually
constitutes a concept that meets the
criteria for scientific evidence
for scientific category.
So we should also talk maybe a little
bit about some different kinds of
categories because it's not all that
obvious to people that there are
different kinds of categories.
So I can,
I can name three very rapidly.
There are many others,
uh,
the first category,
and these are usually the categories
that scientists do investigate.
They are technically called proper sets
and so a proper said is like the set of
all triangles and triangles are clearly
not squares.
We'd all agree on that.
So what makes a triangle different than
the square?
Which one?
Okay,
I was just trying to trip you up there.
So.
Okay.
So,
and is that true of all triangles?
Right,
right,
right.
What about a triangle that has like is
open on one line,
does that qualify as a triangle?
No,
it just looks like a triangle.
It's like an imposter,
so,
okay,
so a proper set has this interesting
characteristic which is it has an
absolutely clear inclusion and exclusion
criteria and there are no exceptions and
so are almost no exceptions.
So you might say,
well,
is the set of all helium atoms a proper
set?
And the answer to that fundamentally is
yes.
And is it distinguishable,
say from the set of all hydrogen atoms
are the set of all iron atoms.
There's,
there's,
there's characteristics that you can
define that precisely indicate the
boundaries of the category and those
sorts of things are,
are relatively easy to study
scientifically because they tend to
behave similarly in different
circumstances.
So here's,
here's another category,
um,
it's called a familial resemblance
category and it's a little harder to
understand,
but I'm a familial resemblance category
is a category that,
that imagine that
the prototypical example is the Smith
brothers.
So the Smith brothers,
here's some things that could
characterize the Smith brothers,
um,
large ears,
large nose,
floppy lips,
a glasses,
mustache,
beard and bald.
So they're obviously not very
attractive.
These Smith brothers.
And then you can tell the Smith brothers
are related to each other because they
all look like each other.
Of course they don't look exactly like
each other.
So one Smith by the brother is bald with
glasses and floppy lips,
but he has little ears.
And then another smith brother has hair,
but he's got,
you know,
large glasses and large ears and sloppy
lips.
And then there's another Smith's brother
that has a big nose and glasses,
but he has nice hair and no and no
mustache but a beard.
And you get the picture.
So,
so
what,
uh,
familial resemblance category.
How a familial resemblance category
works is that there's a list of say 10
attributes.
And in order to be a member of that
class,
you only have to have say four of the
attributes,
any four and,
or maybe five,
whatever.
The weird thing about a familial
resemblance category is that one person
could,
four of the attributes and another
person could have four different
attributes.
If there were 10 attributes that total
and they'd still be members of the same
set even though they don't share any
attributes in common.
And what familial resemblance category
works,
because each of the
members of the category related to a
central prototype and the prototype has
all the features and the prototype might
not even exist.
So there could be a prototypical smith
brother who would have all the
characteristics of the Smith brothers
that I described,
but he doesn't even exist.
He's like,
he's like an amalgam of all the Smith
brothers.
And then each of the Smith brothers are
related in some way to that central
prototype so that you can tell that they
belong in a family and that's not a
proper set.
And one of the things you know you,
you might be asking,
well why should you know this?
And one reason is,
is because it's useful to know that
there are different forms of categories,
but more particularly for psychological
purposes.
Psychiatric diagnostic categories are
familiar with that resemblance
categories.
They're not proper sense.
So if you go into the diagnostic and
statistical manual,
which is the sort of Apa American
Psychiatric Association Bible for doing
diagnosis,
you'll see that if you list the symptoms
of something like a personality
disorder,
there might be 10 symptoms.
And in order to have that personality
disorder,
you only need four of them,
and so there can be wide variation
within the category.
And of course then that begs the
question of whether or not it's actually
a category of certainly whether or not
it's actually a scientific category.
So,
um,
not guy named Barcelona talked about a
different kind of category.
He called them ad hoc categories and
these are strange things like here's,
here's an ad hoc category for you,
things to take out of your apartment
when it's on fire.
So what things would those be?
Pictures?
Yeah.
Pets.
Yes.
Children
forgot about that.
Okay.
What else?
What's that?
Seniors.
Yes.
Hopefully.
Or.
Yeah,
sure.
Insurance id.
Maybe.
What's that?
Anything else?
Okay.
Now you might say,
well,
what are all those things have in common
since there apparently a category.
Yeah,
there are things you care about.
Yeah.
Id.
Do you care about that?
You need it?
Yeah.
So they're necessary or
emotionally valuable or,
or what,
or valuable.
Yeah.
Are irreplaceable in some ways.
Okay.
So that's a funny category.
And one in Barcelona is claims was that
ad hoc categories can become automatic
categories,
perceptual categories if you practice
them enough.
So Bursa would say a fireman has a
better ad hoc category of what to take
out of an apartment during a fire than
you do because he's practiced that using
that category frequently.
So those are categories that sort of
have pragmatic utility.
And that's another kind of category.
Okay.
So I'd mentioned family resemblance,
proper set,
and ad hoc categories.
That's all I can sort of spin off and
in,
in real time here.
So I'm
generally what you're trying to do when
you extract a word out from the
language,
you have to demonstrate it,
that it has the characteristics of a
proper set before you can think of it as
having some genuinely objective
existence.
And that turns out to be a very
difficult thing to do.
So.
And it's one of the things that throws
psychologists for a loop constantly
because we make the presupposition that
just because the word two different
words exist for something that that
signifies to different things or two
things at all.
And so it's,
it's,
it's difficult to disentangle your
description of the world from the world
itself,
but hypothetically,
this construct validation process with
regards to questionnaires is one of the
ways that you can step forward towards
doing that.
I mentioned convergent and discriminant
validity before,
once you get your scale established,
you have to demonstrate,
as I said,
that it measures something that,
that,
that exists in some real way,
and that it also has to be separable for
measures of other things.
So for example,
if you generated up a scale that
measured fun and you found out that it
was highly correlated with other scales
that measure anxiety,
then that would cast some doubt on
whether or not unit you had
appropriately extracted out your scale
for fun and other people would have been
looking at similar things over the
years.
And hopefully your scale would correlate
positively with those similar things and
negatively with the things that you
assume to be different.
And that's convergent and divergent
validity.
And then the criterion related validity,
we're already talked about.
Okay,
so now I want to show you a different,
uh,
powerpoint presentation just for them.
Yeah,
so this,
you might think about this as the
current arguably standard model of human
personality and it's a model that,
this is only half of it by the way.
There's another slide that has the other
half.
This shows the personality of a person
laid out in hierarchy from most general
to most specific.
It's sort of analogous to that little
drawing I showed you of behaviors at the
bottom and then higher order descriptors
at the top,
although they don't map onto each other
one to one.
And that's actually one of the things
I'm trying to figure out.
Um,
it's very difficult to.
It's very difficult to map the trait
theories directly onto the narrative and
the clinical theories.
All right,
so at the highest level of resolution,
here's how people can differ from one
another.
They can be industrious or orderly and
that those two aspects
are quite highly inter correlated,
but in sufficiently differentiable so
that the differences are interesting.
Industriousness in order to dentists
seem to predict different things.
So for example,
industrious,
this seems to be a better predictor of
academic achievement than orderliness
does,
even though they both both clump under
conscientiousness
and then there's volatility in
withdrawal for emotional stability or
neuroticism described different ways.
If it's your neurotic,
if you feel a lot of negative emotion
and you're emotionally stable,
if you don't negative the negative
emotions that are associated with
neuroticism,
we thought for a long time it was all
negative emotions that were associated
with neuroticism,
but it seems to be more like pain and
anxiety and and and pain is somewhat
equivalent to the emotion you feel if
you're frustrated or disappointed or
grieving.
And anxiety seems to be the emotion you
feel when you're subject to
uncontrollable or unexpected
circumstances or when you're subject to
cues of frustration,
disappointment or grief.
So
volatile people
don't really seem to avoid because of
their negative emotion.
Although their emotion,
their,
their emotions bounced a lot,
especially their negative emotions.
So if you're associated with someone
who's voluntell,
what you would observe is that they seem
to overreact to things.
They get more irritated then they
circumstance might seem to indicate and
their emotion,
emotional response to things is on the
negative end is relatively unpredictable
day to day,
so there's a lot of variability and a
lower threshold for the experience.
People who withdraw are people who
appear to be stopped by their
experience,
negative emotion,
so if they're afraid of something,
they won't do it where the volatile
person,
they might do it,
but they'll complain a lot while they're
doing it,
you know,
so we don't know a lot about the
difference between volatility and
withdrawal yet because those have been
recently extracted out using statistical
means and they seem stable,
but exactly what they predict yet,
apart from the few things that I tend to
definitely suggested to you,
isn't yet clear.
Agreeableness sounds like a positive
thing.
Politeness and compassion.
We know that liberals are more
compassionate and conservatives are more
polite,
but we don't know a lot more about the
distinction between politeness and
compassion.
Um,
and we don't know why conservatives are
more polite than liberals are more
compassionate,
but we do know that that appears to be
the case.
We also know by the way that
conservatives are more orderly,
they're less open as well,
which is the dimension we'll talk about
in a moment.
Those three,
those are three of the five big five
traits,
conscientiousness,
emotional stability and agreeableness.
They clumped together to make a super
factor called stability and stability.
Looks like it might be associated with
higher levels of Serotonin.
Serotonin is a major brain
neurotransmitter that seems to regulate
broadly speaking,
emotion and motivation,
and if your serotonin levels so to
speak,
are relatively high,
then you're a relatively stable person
and if your serotonin levels are low,
then you tend to be impulsive and prone
to negative emotion.
Now,
one of the things that's quite
interesting about Serotonin is that it
tracks your position in the dominance
hierarchy as well,
so the higher you are up in a given
dominance hierarchy,
the more serotonin in your brain
produces and that makes you more
confident and less unstable.
And the lower you are in the hierarchy,
the lower your brain serotonin levels.
And the reason for that seems to be that
if you're low in the dominance
hierarchy,
while you should be afraid,
because almost anything can knock you
into oblivion because if you're right at
the bottom of the dominance hierarchy,
you're barely,
hey,
you're barely hanging on and you just
can't tolerate any more threat.
And conversely,
it might also be appropriate for you if
someone dangles a reward in front of you
for you to grab it because it's not
exactly clear,
it's going to be the next day or the
next day.
Whereas if you're up high in the
dominance hierarchy,
it's like you can take a lot of billows
and you're so well situated socially
that it's probably not going to
overwhelm you that much and you don't
have to be impulsive because the
microenvironment that you inhabit is
very stable.
So the negative emotion dimension,
emotional stability,
is particularly associated with
serotonergic function.
But we think that the whole super factor
of stability is associated with
serotonergic tone.
So some of this,
like I mentioned already,
all of these different
aspects,
traits and super factors role derived
statistically,
but evidence has continued to accrue
over the last 20 years with regards to
the biological substrate of the traits.
And so as we progress through them one
by one,
we'll also talk about hypothetically
what constitutes the underlying biology
agreeable people.
Um,
I think the easiest way to conceptualize
agreeableness as is,
as I'm a negotiating strategy in some
sense.
So you know,
you're always attempting to divide up
resources between you and other people.
And a disagreeable person will make a
pretty damn strong case that the
resources should go to them.
Whereas an agreeable person will be much
more likely to under represent their own
interest and over represent the interest
of others.
And so,
you know,
in some ways people like that are very
pleasant to be around,
you know,
because they're always doing things for
other people on.
Unfortunately they're often not doing
enough for themselves.
In my clinical practice,
I can always tell who the agreeable
people are because when they come and
see me,
they bring me coffee.
The disagreeable people bring themselves
coffee,
so yeah,
sure.
Pretty sad animation.
The aspects here,
so openness.
Remember you guys hypothesize that
intelligence was unrelated to fund I'll
find is pretty much an extroversion sub
element.
And intelligence is associated with
openness and it roughly breaks down like
this.
So,
um,
Iq is probably a better measure of the
aspect.
Intellect Iq tests are a better measure
of the subscale intellect than
personality measures are.
So what it means is that for,
for intellect,
for intelligence,
we have a measure that isn't merely self
report and it's a good measure.
And we'll talk a lot about intelligence.
It's actually a very easy,
it's a simple thing to conceptualize.
So,
um,
it's a,
it's a more difficult thing to try to
explain,
but conceptually it's fairly
straightforward.
Um,
the other aspect of openness is openness
proper.
I put creativity here and what that
seems to be associated with is the
degree to which someone is a variety of
things,
but one of them seems to be the degree
to which a given idea.
If you throw someone an idea or you
offer someone idea,
there's some probability that that's
going to make them think of other
things.
The more open someone is,
the more likely it is that any given
idea is gonna,
make them think of more things and also
the open person has a more diverse range
of things that that idea might bring
about and so often a speaking style of
someone who's open is associated is
characterized by relatively loose
associations.
I mean
that like my lectures for example,
so it's a measure of creativity,
but it's also a measure in some sense of
lack of constraint on,
on the propagation of ideas through the
idea network and I don't know exactly
what that means neurologically.
I do know that you can be relatively
high and intelligence and relatively low
in openness or creativity,
but the two things do tend to go very.
So for example,
it's very rare for people to make any
major contribution to a creative sphere
unless they have an Iq of over least
over 120.
So it's a pretty.
It's pretty selective one in 20,
120.
That's about the 90th 91st 92nd
percentile.
So it's pretty high.
So openness is creativity and
intelligence.
It's a bit broader than that too though,
because open people are also more
capable of aesthetic experience.
So it's not only that they are more
creative,
but they also enjoy the products of
creative endeavor more than non open
people.
So open people are going to be
interested in dance and music and poetry
and philosophy.
Um,
they're characterized by the capacity
for aesthetic experiences,
you know,
so some people can listen to music and
the hair on the back of their neck stand
up or maybe they get the same sensation
when they're watching someone dance or.
So I'm just out of curiosity,
if you're inclined to answer,
how many of you have had the experience
of,
it's called [inaudible] erection
actually,
because sometimes the hairs on your arms
will stand up to as a consequence of
watching something that's aesthetic
movie or how many.
Quite a lot of you.
How many haven't.
Okay.
So while there's a lot of,
you know,
by that measure anyways,
there's a lawful lot of open people in
this class.
So,
um,
that sense,
by the way of having your hairs on the
back of your neck stand up,
that's sort of a remnant of the pilot
erection reflex.
So you know,
let's say you,
you,
you're watching a cat and the cat comes
around a corner and all of a sudden
there's a dog there.
What happens to the cat goes right puffs
right up.
Even.
So now it's tales about this big around
right?
And when it started,
but it puffs right out and it's like
that's an automatic reflex on the part
of the cat.
Now it's trying to look like it's big.
You know,
Chris,
the dog will do the same thing,
so it's a bit counterproductive.
But whatever the cat's trying to look
like,
it occupies a lot more space than it
actually looks like.
And,
but there's also,
at least in principle and emotion
associated with that,
which is one of,
it's sort of a combination of terror and
all.
And maybe that's what the cat seals.
But that's what they are experience of
awe.
Even filtered down is still associated
with that,
you know,
experience of pilot direction.
So that's pretty interesting.
So extroverted people,
or at least I think it's pretty
interesting,
extroverted people are assertive and
enthusiastic and so the enthusiasm
dimension seems to be associated with a
lot of overt,
positive emotion.
And so extroverts in many ways are more
fun and they laugh more.
They talk more.
That is not necessarily more fun.
They're very gregarious.
They like to hang out at parties.
They planned parties,
they tell jokes,
in fact,
telling a joke is actually a real marker
of,
of extroversion.
So how many of you here tell jokes?
Yeah,
how many don't.
Okay.
So,
um,
how many of you tell good jokes
anyways?
So yeah,
I'm also one of the behavioral markers
we found for extroversion was that
extroverted people also tell dirty
jokes.
So how many of you are capable of that
particular act?
Yeah.
So you in particular,
you.
All right?
So yeah.
So the assertiveness element of
extroversion.
That's,
I guess sometimes that's the part of
extroversion that maybe isn't so much
fun because extroverts can be very
verbally dominant.
One of the things I do in my fourth year
undergraduate personality seminar is I
split the group and take introverts.
And extroverts,
so because I often have the class do
debates and if if you put an extrovert
in with a bunch of introverts and
there's a debate,
so there's one extrovert here in three
introverts and one extrovert here at
three introverts.
Then the two extroverts have the debate
and the introverts don't say anything
and introverts are interesting because
it's not like they don't have anything
to say because if you pointed an
introvert and say,
do you have something to say?
Then they'll say something that they're
thinking,
but they'll very rarely,
especially if they're very introverted,
they're very rarely offered
spontaneously.
And so if I found that if I divide the
class into two groups of introverts in
two groups of extroverts and then I have
them do like a four way debate.
The introverts so talk like mad in,
in their,
in their own group,
you know,
because they're not being overpowered by
an extrovert.
The extrovert seemed to have a much
lower threshold for,
for speaking.
It doesn't take much of a stimulus to
get them talking or they have a real
impulse to talk.
Like my daughter is super introverted or
extroverted.
It's impossible for her to think
something without saying it,
so I know which is not always to her
benefit,
but I,
I extroverts have a real impulse to
speech,
you know,
whereas introverts,
they have to be sort of prodded into it.
Extroverts also seemed to be sort of,
um,
what would you call it?
Energized by social interactions.
You know,
they'll go to a party and they get more
and more and more energy.
An introvert will go to a party and it's
like there'll be there for an hour and
then they've had enough people and they
want to go home and sit in their room
and recharge.
And it isn't exactly,
we really don't have any idea why that
is,
but it seems to be a pretty reliable
marker of the difference between the two
groups.
Here's some what?
Um,
let's see.
Yeah.
Well here's some items so you guys can
do a quick,
big five on yourselves and I'll tell you
the upside and downside of it.
So
if you're orderly,
you follow a schedule,
Dominique,
view,
follow a schedule.
Okay?
Now how many of you don't.
Okay.
So one thing I would recommend is that
you do,
and I'll tell you why,
like intelligence is a very good
predictor of academic performance
and there's not a lot you can do about
your intelligence.
I mean you can squander it,
but it's very difficult to improve it.
Conscientiousness,
well it's a trait too so it's hard to
work on,
but we know that conscientious people
get better grades and it's reliable and
it's a powerful effect.
And so if your time use organized than
the probability that you're going to be
successful is very high.
So one of the things you might think
about is make friends with a calendar
like Google calendar or something like
that.
And I can tell you some tricks about
that because really it is important
like,
and I'm not kidding around about this.
If you're low in conscientiousness,
it's really going to trip you up as you
walk through life.
There's not very many advantages to it
that I've been able to see.
And I'm not assuming that just because
you don't follow a schedule,
you're low in conscientiousness,
but it is one of the items that market,
um,
the only,
the advantage I've seen so far to being
unconscientious is that if you become
unemployed it doesn't bother you as
much.
And I mean that,
that actually turns out to matter in
some situations.
So like,
you know,
if a big company has to shed and 50
percent of its employees,
it's the conscientious people are going
to suffer themselves to death for it.
And the unconscientious people,
they're not going to care anyways
because they weren't working anyway.
So it doesn't matter if they have a job
or not.
So here's one way of thinking about
making use of a schedule.
Often people are afraid of schedules
because they think of them as a trap.
You know,
you make a schedule and it's like this
little prison that you have to live
inside and you know,
and all you're doing in your schedule is
putting down things you have to do or
should do.
And so,
you know,
there's not a lot of fun in that.
And so not only is it a trap or a
prison,
but it's kind of an unpleasant one,
but a way to work with the schedule in a
lot more sophisticated way is to think,
well,
I'm going to plan the next week say
because you plan it day by day,
but we'll take the week as the unit
level of analysis and think,
well I'd like to plan a week I'd like to
have.
Then your schedule all of a sudden
becomes a tool for increasing the
quality of your life.
And that's a whole different issue,
you know,
because you might think what,
what's the emotion that you suffer
assuming you suffer one of these
emotions,
if you have an essay that's due and
you're not doing it,
like would you regard that as a pleasant
emotion or unpleasant?
The bullshit.
Okay.
So is there anybody who is disagreeing
with a statement that having an essay
due or overdue that you're not doing is
unpleasant?
Everyone agrees with that.
Okay.
Do you think you can characterize the
unpleasantness?
Like what kind of emotion is it?
It's guilt.
Okay.
Anything else?
Frustration,
frustration with what
you feel like a failure.
Yeah.
So you're sort of frustrated with
yourself.
Yeah.
You need to slap right?
Do you think I need a slap?
So.
Okay.
So guilt.
Anything else?
Anxiety,
restlessness.
So that's kind of an agitation.
Yeah.
It's because your body knows you should
be doing something but you know,
you're not pointing it in the right
direction.
So it's
a shame.
Is that a reasonable?
So.
Okay.
So the reason I was asking you about
that is because,
you know,
most of the negative emotions are
associated with neuroticism,
but some of them seem to be associated
with conscientiousness and
conscientious.
Negative emotions seem to be guilt and
shame fundamentally.
And so recent research and really
recent,
I already got this paper like a week
ago,
I think it's about four months old,
seem to indicate that conscientious
people feel less guilt,
but they're more guilt prone.
So if they don't do something that makes
them guilty,
but they organize their time so they are
doing the things they're supposed to do
so then they don't feel guilty.
So anyways,
back to the schedule.
So.
Alright,
you think about your week and you think
about your day and you think,
well,
how would you improve the quality of a
given day or given week?
Well,
one of the ways of improving it is to
not put yourself into the situation
where there are things hanging over your
head that you have to feel guilty and
ashamed about because that's a very
unpleasant way of being.
And you know,
if you have an essay,
it's due in a week and you're
procrastinating,
then the fact that you have to do that
so it can ruin the whole week.
And even when you're doing something
that's positive hypothetically,
it's kind of that horrible kind of
positive that you experienced when you
know that you should be doing something
else.
And so that's when you ended up watching
youtube videos about like dancing cats
or something like that.
You know,
and it's,
it's,
it's at best.
It's a guilty pleasure.
It's not a pleasure at all.
You think like,
what the hell am I doing?
Watching videos of dancing cats,
you know,
but then you know that you're
procrastinating and that's low quality,
very low quality existence.
So if you use your schedule,
you can think,
okay,
well here's some times that I'm going to
do this work,
and then you can also sort of ask
yourself about that when you're
designing your schedule because you
don't want to design a schedule like
your Adolf Hitler telling yourself what
to do,
you know,
because you're not going to comply with
it.
Then what you have to do if you're going
to design a schedule,
so you have to ask yourself,
all right,
I'm going to set aside some time to
study over the next week or two,
do this essay or whatever it is.
How much time would I actually spend
studying?
And you know,
I'm going to go to the library for four
hours a day.
It's like,
how many of you go to the library for
four hours a day?
You do,
how much work do you do during those
four hours?
You do?
That's very impressive.
Is it more than four hours?
And so what proportion of the time
you're spending there do you think is
actually efficient?
Hmm.
That's good.
My suspicions are that you're
conscientious.
So that's,
that's exceptional.
I mean people usually don't manage that
so,
but you know,
an hour or two a day might be a
worthwhile thing to schedule it and I
would say don't schedule in more than
that to begin with because then you'll
fail and then you'll stop using the
schedule.
And so the other thing you want to do is
you want to schedule and things that you
want to do and then you want to look at
the day or the week and you think you
want to think,
hey that's a week I'd like to have.
If I had a week like that,
it would be good.
You know,
I'd be caught up so.
So that all that negative emotion
doesn't have to accrue.
I don't want to down a bunch of things
that I'm interested in doing and at the
end of the week I'd be in better shape
than I was at the beginning.
And if you treat a schedule like that so
that what you're using it is to design
the days and weeks that you want to have
instead of using it as this little you
know,
jail that you have to put yourself in
that you're not going to do anyways,
then you can learn to use them.
And that's one thing you could do to
make yourself more industrious or,
or,
uh,
more conscientiousness,
more conscientious follow a schedule am
not bothered by disorder.
So how many of you people are not
bothered by disorder?
Okay.
And how many of you are bothered by
disorder?
Yes.
So some of those of you who are bothered
by disorder probably have an eating
disorder.
That would be my guess.
I'm not going to ask,
but that would be my guess because one
of the things that does characterize
people who are,
who have eating disorders,
they tend to be very orderly and
orderly.
People tend to be quite sensitive to
discussed and discussed.
Seems to be the driving factor behind
eating disorders because people who have
body dysmorphia or eating disorders tend
to be relatively disgusted by what they
see as you know,
inadequacies in their own body,
so orderliness can get out of hand a
lot.
We have some suspicions that it's maybe
also associated with authoritarianism in
political viewpoints because
conservatives are more conscientious
than liberals,
but it's specifically they tend to be
more orderly.
So under that doesn't mean orderliness
is a bad thing.
It just means,
and this is something to think about
with regards to all the traits that any
trade exaggerated too far starts to
become negative.
So the big five traits,
at least in principle,
don't have any,
what would you call it?
Intrinsic moral value.
And that's partly because too much of a
good thing seems to turn very rapidly
into a really bad thing.
So having a healthy personality seems to
be more like something like the balance
between the different traits and maybe
also something like your ability to
increase the breadth of your traits.
You know,
so maybe if you're hyper orderly,
one of the things that would be good for
you to learn is to not be hyper orderly
in every situation all the time.
It's too rigid.
So okay,
so orderly people are bothered by
disorder and they follow a schedule.
And so a industrious people
do not waste their time and they know
what they're doing.
So how many of you people
don't waste your time?
So two people.
Okay,
I've,
I've played it.
How much time do you waste with you
before I have?
Okay,
that's too bad because I love torturing
undergraduates at that game.
Okay.
So that's another advantage to a
schedule,
you know,
because it can,
it can really help you with time
wasting.
And that's something that'll kill you.
Kill you over time.
Um,
how many of you have good goals and you
know,
and know what you're doing.
Yeah.
So that's better.
How many of you don't.
How many of you don't know really what
you're doing or where you're going?
Okay.
So,
okay,
so that's conscientiousness,
neuroticism,
volatile.
People get angry,
easy and they don't keep their emotions
under control.
What that should have been reversed by
the way,
I'm withdrawal seldom feel blue.
It's the opposite.
I'm filled with or sorry,
sell them.
Feel blue is at the opposite,
am filled with doubts about things
that's seems like more of a depression
trait.
Withdrawal,
so that's a negative emotion dimension,
so people reliably differ on the degree
to which the experience negative emotion
and the degree to which they experienced
positive emotion and those two things
are actually different because the
circuitry that operates positive emotion
is a particular circuit and the circuits
that operate negative emotion,
our particular circuits,
and they're not merely opposites so you
can be highly neurotic and very
extroverted and so that means you're
always at parties,
but you're continually worrying what
people are thinking of you.
So it's people like that are actually
quite complicated.
You know,
so it's,
it's,
it's a complicated
combination of traits.
Agreeableness,
polite people,
respect authority,
and they do not believe that they're
better than others.
And Compassionate people are interested
in other people's problems and take time
for other people.
So
I'll tell you this after we do it at
extroversion,
open people.
We talked about this already,
if you're creative,
you believe in the importance of art,
you love to reflect on things.
If you're smart,
which is sort of the intellect category,
you're quick to understand things and
can handle a lot of information and then
extroverted people are assertive,
they take charge,
they're able to influence people,
so they're kind of charismatic and if
they're enthusiastic,
they make friends easily and are easy to
get to know
it might be of some interest to you that
disagreeable
people
who are
extroverted are narcissistic.
So
because a disagreeable person doesn't,
isn't particularly applied,
they don't really care about your
feelings and they're very dominant.
So and uh,
so if you're like that,
it would be useful to learn when to be
quieter and social situations and how to
attend more to other people.
One of the things that seems quite
useful for people who are disagreeable
and narcissistic for that matter is to
try consciously on a regular basis to do
something for someone else.
It also actually seems to make people
who are narcissistic,
happier to do that.
Interestingly enough.
Okay.
So
I'll just briefly also talk about
general cognitive ability is sort of an.
Excuse me,
it's an overview of where we're going to
head over the next few courses.
This is a Raven's progressive matrices
test.
I don't think this one is very
difficult,
although I'm.
I'm going to look at it before.
I certainly tell you that because I
don't want you to feel bad.
Oh,
and the answer is there anyway.
So it actually turns out to be extremely
easy.
So why is seven the right answer?
Hmm.
Okay.
Say that again.
It has to be the lowest.
Why?
Why does it have to be the lowest?
And then the squares at the top.
Right?
So there has to be in,
there has to be an item at the bottom.
Okay.
And be a little circle.
And it has to be trying have to be a
triangle because it's the only thing
missing,
right?
Because every other rowers triangle.
So you inferred all that by analyzing
the three by three matrix.
Okay.
The faster you can do that
and
it's an interaction between speed and
complexity.
You could make these questions much more
complex than this one.
This one's,
you know,
reasonably complex,
but they can get really vicious because
maybe there's what,
two dimensions of variation here.
There's whether or not it's an oval,
a triangle,
and a rectangle,
and then where the thing is,
that's it.
But you could imagine you could make a
matrix with like four dimensions of
variability.
And so these tests turn out to be the
most accurate tests of general cognitive
ability.
Raven's progressive matrices.
That's not verbal intelligence,
it's nonverbal intelligence.
But,
um,
and I can tell you why it is that these
tests turned out to be that way later.
And I will.
General cognitive ability is a very good
predictor of life success and it seems
to be very much biologically.
Um,
what would you say biological factors
play a large role,
especially in modern society and
determining relative levels of
intelligence,
which is a relatively rough.
It's a rough fact.
Okay.
So we'll sum up briefly.
It looks like there's five basic
dimensions of variability
that characterize the human personality,
conscientiousness,
emotional stability,
agreeableness,
openness and extroversion.
And what we'll do as we progress through
the rest of the,
or at least the next,
roughly a little more than a third of
the classes,
will delineate each of these variables,
try to understand precisely what they
mean,
see if we can analyze their effect on
society and maybe also provide you with
the opportunity to get some more insight
into the personality traits that you
have.
The exercise,
the personality,
self analysis,
the adjectives that were in there were
taken from the big five models.
And so,
you know,
that sort of gave you an opportunity to
assess yourself roughly on a big,
on the big five dimensions and see what
you could do to improve.
So we'll see you on Thursday.